[Applause]
the newest Jurassic world installment is
upon us like a hungry t-rex who doesn't
have any feathers for some reason here's
a few things Hollywood is still getting
wrong about dinosaurs many dinosaurs had
feathers but the dinosaurs of Jurassic
world are covered in scales like
crocodiles and lizards they might have
made an effort to stick in a few
feathers on this dinosaur but even if
they did that's not a real animal it's a
hybrid of two different species which
brings us to our next point genetics
doesn't work that way this is the most
dangerous creature sure some species can
breed that's how you get a liger but the
endo Raptor isn't like a liger it's a
mix of a type of Tyrannosaur and raptor
two very different kinds of animals it
would be more like if you try to breed a
lion with a wolf instead it's just not
gonna happen
the DNA isn't compatible
[Music]
dinosaurs didn't roar in the first
Jurassic world t-rexes roar was made
from a mix of animal sounds and it
sounds pretty similar in the new film
but dinosaurs didn't roar like a lion
they're related to birds which means
their voice box was probably similar to
a bird's Raptors had wings
first of all wrapped your hands didn't
droop down like that in reality that
would only happen if their wrists were
broken in truth
Raptors like birds today had wings they
couldn't fly but the wing shape means
their arms look nothing like this
dinosaurs were colorful yeah
Jurassic world's dinosaurs are way too
dull
sure earth tones like green and brown
are common in today's reptiles but
paleontologists have found that
dinosaurs came in a kaleidoscope of
bright colors just like today's birds
some even had shiny iridescent feathers
we get it Hollywood t-rex is scarier
with its iconic roar
and velociraptors looked more vicious
without those ridiculous feathers but
come on you could at least add a little
more color maybe next time it was all
alive this video was made in large part
thanks to paleontologist Steve Bruce
Soddy author of the rise and fall of the
dinosaurs